all right a new trailer for Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 this is technically the
first official trailer full trailer
that's not a teaser let's go ahead and
see where we're in store for here maybe
some foreshadowing of somebody
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
that girl died but then she came back
she came back a totaled dick
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
music is always spot on James Gunn the
Guardians there he is nice
is to create the perfect Society rocket
he didn't want to make things perfect I
don't like it
you just hated things the way they are I
that's new
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight this side my friends
incinerate them oh Adam Warlock
fruit oh
I'm not gonna this is gonna
we're always searching for a family
isn't how we found each other
are you ready what was that for one last
ride
yo Drax was totally shot in the
headphones or in the Chester right away
together
into the forever
[Music]
that beautiful sky
[Applause]
rocket was drinking something
[Music]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into nothing
knock it off what I've never noticed how
black your eyes were they were replaced
by my father as a method of torture he
he picked a pretty set
I'm so worried oh sorry it's funny but
I didn't like rocket as a baby being
experimented on especially because I
named my cat rocket after Rocket Raccoon
but
um
I I know some Guardians aren't making it
out alive that one shot it looked like
Drax literally got shot in the chest
um I know he's tough but that's a hard
thing to survive but
I don't know but the movie looks amazing
it looks like you know the other
Guardians movies which are amazing I'm
really looking forward to this one I
think it's definitely going to be one of
the best phase five movies so let me
know what your thoughts are about this
trailer and comments down below if you
have any predictions on who's gonna die
sadly
let me know about that too in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe we talk about Marvel News
Daily here on the channel uh you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf